are you doing well how are you good have
you seen this good I have I would you
think I loved it what did you think good
so many times when you were I neither
like junior high or high school the
thing that you always say is God why
can't my life be like the movies
hmm now this is that movie for a pain
really isn't what isn't that like that
you are now that movie oh my god well I
think it's special and I think that it's
very necessary especially in 2020 I
think that the the rapid kind of aging
of these generations is pretty real just
in terms of what they're looking for
what kids are looking for nowadays and
their access their general access I mean
like when I was a middle school junior
high like it was I have a crush I have
feelings
I'll tell them great and then maybe I'll
go home and call their landline yeah and
it's not mad anymore
it's instantaneous yes you know I say
something to one person they text
somebody like by the end of the day the
entire school knows you know but that's
honest it's very real I think proper
representation of that in all and always
proper representation of just general
life right now in the work space in
school whatever the case may be I think
it's a very very necessary thing and I
think that that's done so well Jenny Han
obviously created a beautiful character
representing you know Asian Americans
and the fact that she's half Korean half
white is like it's a pretty awesome
thing in the fact that that is our lead
and she's charming and fashionable and
smart and willing to take on challenges
and things is a really beautiful thing
and I think that also just being able to
see yourself and a lot of different
people is also very necessary
Valentine's Day this comes in around
Valentine's Day sets up for me so the
movie is going to be the focal point for
a couple who are dating maybe not yet in
love okay you like on their way great so
the movies gonna be the anchor okay give
me some other things to sort of fill out
that night
I mean uh if you're of age I think a
beautiful wine okay um you know I'm like
a wine a little a little cheese a little
you know deli meats um maybe some
chocolate at the end of it I think the
conversation is really important what
date night is concerned I think that
however you bookend it it needs to be
over conversation right and so I allowed
them film to be a focal point a
beautiful focal point - might I add you
could do experience a handful of
different relationships and like how
they can all kind of unfold over the
course of this film and it's very honest
and I think would incite some great
conversations between the two of you but
I think as long as you can like start it
off with a little banter watch the film
actually watch the phone okay okay let's
let's do that let's throw that in there
and then end it with some like some some
good conversation I think well it'll be
a beautiful night before I let you go so
we know Noah's he-man
yeah you've done a voice in Shira yes
how do we get you Noah Lana
everybody all in yes we know the
chemistry works right how does that
happen right there's so many ways that
it could be approached I mean you know
we were actually talking about it the
other day III don't know how that
specifically could happen I'm a huge of
a nerd I'm a wee anime Marvel read
comics growing up like video games
obviously is a very big part of my life
and my career now as well I would love
to I would love for Sony and Marvel to
all figure things out and for Marvel
Disney to actually be able to do
fantastic for really really do it for me
to play Johnny Storm for Lana to play
soo yeah for us to both be like adopted
siblings and for Noah to play Reed
Richards yeah like let me be the cool
like on a badass and let Noah be the
doctor right and like let's let's do
this you know we'll find our Ben Grimm
wouldn't that be fun love that let me
flame on around us would finally do it
right well I think we would you would
absolutely do it right thank you thank
you thank you